[Applaus]
ja liebe Zuschauer die ganzen Zeiten
wenden die sind wir inzwischen weißgott
gewöhnt eine Zeitenwende nach der
anderen aber diese Woche gab es eine
regelrechte Metamorphose und ich spreche
natürlich von Olaf Scholz ja bis neulich
der wahrscheinlich leiseste Kanzler den
wir jemals hatten jetzt gibt er
plötzlich ein Interview nach dem anderen
und er hat den Lautstärkeregler gefunden
aber es muss einen Bürger der Ukraine
zynisch vorkommen wenn ihm gesagt wird
er solle sich gegen die Putins
Aggression ohne Waffen verteidigen das
ist aus der Zeit gefallen
ja
kurz danach hat auf der Bühne noch eine
Gitarre kaputt geschlagen
von wegen schlumpfiges Grinsen der Olaf
kann auch anders Freunde aber wirklich
und das hatte jetzt bewiesen immer mal
ganz abgesehen davon dass der Kanzler da
inhaltlich total recht hatte bei der
Rede versteht man ja auch seine neue
Emotionalität was der sich anhören muss
der Mann zum Beispiel vom ukrainischen
Botschafter Melnik Stichwort
leberwurstgate
beleidigte Leberwurst beleidigt der
Leberwurst beleidigte Leberwurst
beleidigte der Leberwurst beleidigte
beleidigt den Leberwurst
[Applaus]
oder auf Französisch so sister
aber gut die wurstkrise und der
reisestreit sind seit gestern abgehakt
der Knoten ist geplatzt bald kommt
bärbock nach Kiel danach wahrscheinlich
Steinmeier dann Scholz wenn es blöd
läuft irgendwann auch Philipp amtop
alles prima
alles prima aber Friedrich Merz war
vorher da ja März hat den diplomatischen
Durchbruch geschafft also sagt März
sein Besuch sein Besuch in Kiefer eben
keine reine Symbolpolitik wir haben
jetzt herzlich willkommen nach Kiew das
ist eine symbolische Besuch
ja haben sie es gemerkt man sieht kurz
im Gesicht von März er will
widersprechen aber dann fällt ihm ein
was Klitschko früher beruflich gemacht
hat
so und jetzt liefert Deutschland sie
haben es bestimmt gelesen also auch noch
Panzerhaubitzen an die Ukraine und die
Diskussion über schwere Waffen geht
weiter 28 Prominente haben dazu in Ali
schwarzes Emma ein offenen Brief an den
Kanzler veröffentlicht kurz zurück Frage
Brief wirklich haben wir 1812 oder was
schickt doch wenigstens eine offenes Fax
oder sowas keine Ahnung
unterzeichnet man das ganze von
Gelehrten und Schauspielern und es war
ein Ja sagen wir mal exzellent
formulierte Aufruf an die Ukraine
beizeiten zu kapitulieren klar ich
privat finde es immer besser wenn man
als Pazifist eher Forderung an den
Aggressor stellt und nicht an dessen
Opfer aber hey ist eine legitime Debatte
gelegentlich vielleicht ein Tick zu laut
aber zu diesem Kompromiss ist uns damals
wollen sie raus
liefern
ja ich darf jetzt vielleicht ich möchte
darauf hinaus vielleicht darf ich jetzt
einmal kurz danke schön für das Gespräch
ich bitte Sie gerne
sehr gerne nichts geht über ein
natürliches Lächeln meine Damen und
Herren so selbstverständlich kann man
gegen die Lieferung von schweren Waffen
sein klar aber wenn deutsche
Intellektuelle den Ukrainern von hier
aus erklären wie viel Widerstand aus
ihrer Sicht noch sinnvoll ist muss ich
leider kotzen
Putins Geheimdienst musste ihm übrigens
erstmal erklären wer den ominösen Brief
geschrieben hat
also das ist eine Gruppe von deutschen
Intellektuellen und Schauspielern Lars
Eidinger zum Beispiel der hat echt ein
paar ganz gute Sachen gemacht und ähm
Alice schwarz sein
die Tante von der AFD nee das ist Alice
Weidel die ist blond Alice Schwarzer
gibt ja die Emma raus diese Zeitschrift
für Frauenrechte für was also Kollege
ich kenne Rechte Frauen aber was bitte
sind Frauenrechte willst du mich
verarschen oder was
ja bei dir schon ein mutiger Mann so und
was den Brief angeht fürs Protokoll klar
Angst vor dem Atomkrieg haben wir alle
alles andere wäre ja verrückt man darf
eben nur nie vergessen das Putin seine
inzwischen ritualisierten
weltkriegsdrohungen sehr strategisch
einsetzt sehr um uns zu spalten und zu
lähmen ist ja klar im russischen
Fernsehen haben sie neulich vorgerechnet
mit einem Schaubild das eine Rakete nach
Berlin nur 106 Sekunden braucht man
lernt überhaupt viel über Deutschland
wenn man bei denen mal reinsetzt wussten
Sie zum Beispiel dass wir alle längst
wieder Nazis sind ja wirklich
das deutsche Unternehmen reinmetall hat
angekündigt dass es 88 Leopard Panzer in
die Ukraine liefern können 50 alte und
der Rest neu welche Bedeutung hat die
Zahl 88 das ist ein Skandal 88 Gebote
des Neofaschismus basierend auf dem 8
Kapitel aus Hitlers Mein Kampf das 88
Worte enthält
was nimmt er denn
okay 88 ist ja tatsächlich ein alter
nazikot für Heil Hitler Achter Buchstabe
H im Alphabet kurz danach hat derselbe
Experte ernsthaft gesagt unsere
Bundesregierung würde sich offen zum
Neofaschismus bekennen ja wirklich und
der Beweis
der Beweis sind halt die erwähnten 88
Panzer ist eigentlich ein Wunder dass
uns die Russen da jetzt erst auf die
Schliche kommen die Indizien waren so
offensichtlich
[Musik]
scheinbar ein weltoffenes
Modernisierungsprojekt doch sie haben
uns alle getäuscht in Wirklichkeit sind
das durch die Bank Nazis der russische
Geheimdienst hat jetzt wasserdichte
Beweise erfunden 17 Regierungsmitglieder
die Quersumme ist 8 also schon wieder
Hitler einer der Minister heißt ganz
offen Hubertus Heil ebenfalls mit dabei
Svenja Schulze Initialen SS super ihre
Parteichefin ist die gefürchtete sa skia
esken die Farben der Ampel sind rot gelb
und grün aber wenn man die mischt genau
braun und jetzt kommt der eigentliche
Hammer der reichsfinanzminister liebt
Hunde genau wie Hitler sonst noch
parallelen denke ich an Autobahn
Autobahn Autobahn Autobahn keine
weiteren Fragen
ja
sind wir aufgeflogen
das darf man alles nicht persönlich
nehmen für ein Putin sind alle Nazis
außer eher jedenfalls im Moment so mal
wie geht das jetzt weiter und zwar
jenseits von Waffenlieferungen zum
Beispiel mit einem Ölboykott der
Europäischen Union nimmt das Vladimir so
gut tatsächlich das ist die Realität
kaufen die Europäer noch bis zum
Jahresende russisches Öl Ungarn und die
Slowakei mindestens bis Ende 23 so das
Putin noch Monate Zeit hat seine
schwarze Plörre an andere Kunden zum
Beispiel in Indien zu verticken während
der Ölpreis weiter durch die Decke geht
ist blöd ist wirklich blöd hier Robert
Habeck hat genau das Problem früher
erkannt nur kann erst natürlich viel
schöner ausdrücken als ich der Schaden
aber überkompensiert wird weil der
Ölpreis weltweit durch die Decke geht
und man mit weniger Ölexporten noch mehr
Einnahmen staatlicherseits und zwar
russischerseits verbuchen kann also
Putin mehr Geld verdien in dem mal
weniger Öl verkauft dann haben wir mit
Zitronen gehandelt bzw mit Öl gehandelt
aber in dieser Woche Zitrone gebissen
ja ja da hätte bekannte Ausdruck
Zitronen nach Athen tragen
beziehungsweise Moskau aber
natürlich ist das Öl embargo an sich
schon ein wichtiges Signal der EU
überlegen Sie mal alleine seid
Kriegsbeginn hat Deutschland Putin 9
Milliarden Euro für fossile Brennstoffe
überwiesen mehr als jedes andere Land
der Welt der müsste eigentlich wie so
ein Bundesliga-Trainer hier auf seinem
Hemdkragen stehen nach powered by
Germany ja ich finde es wirklich
deprimierend genau wie unsere
Abhängigkeit von seinem Gas was wenn er
uns doch noch seinerseits den Hahn
zudreht so genau dazu gab es jetzt
endlich mal einen innovativen Vorschlag
und zwar aus dem Aufsichtsrat des
Energiekonzerns E.ON so fordert der
Aufsichtsratsvorsitzende von Eon Carl
Ludwig Kley die Politik sollte sehr
ernsthaft darüber nachdenken ob Sie die
Reihenfolge nicht umdreht und erst bei
dem privaten abschaltet und dann bei der
Industrie
okay
nächsten Winter sollen wir also alle zu
Hause frieren damit die Industrie weiter
Gas hat das ist doch mal erfrischender
Ansatz wir schalten mal live zu Herrn
Kleist Pressesprecherin Valerie Niehaus
vor der e.on-zentrale in Essen von hier
aus ihr Chef hat aber mal richtig Bock
auf den Shitstorm kann das sein ja
Entschuldigung was ist denn die
Alternative da sitzen wir im Herbst vor
der aufgedrehten Heizung sind aber alle
arbeitslos der Mensch definiert sich
doch durch seine Arbeit wenn sie morgen
ihren Job verlieren sitzen bei Ihnen zu
Hause auch nur noch 110 Kilo Biomasse
nutzlos vor der Glotze also fragen sie
mal ihre Frau ob die das so schön fände
das wird jetzt aber doch unnötig
persönlich finde ich von hier aus also
in Krisenzeiten darf man keine Angst
haben auch mal anzuecken ja der Herr
Kley hat noch so viele tolle Ideen im
Köcher Beispiel in Deutschland leben
rund 15 Millionen Katzen und zehn
Millionen Hunde und diese Tiere
es gibt viele gar nicht wissen arbeiten
alle nichts Beitrag zum
Bruttosozialprodukt 0 so warum nicht
einfach mal quer gedacht diese Hunde und
Katzen zum Bio-Sprit verkochen ja hier
neue Plakate Kampagne Eon wir tanken
Welpen
damit rechnet Putin nicht ja ich weiß
aber nicht ob die deutschen das so
mitmachen das ist die neue Härte die
liegt voll im Trend Andreas Pinkwart NRW
Wirtschaftsminister schlägt vor im
Herbst doch wieder alle ins Homeoffice
zu schicken damit die Firmen nicht ihre
Büros heizen müssen verstehen sie wir
sparen Geld ihr heizt ja und das gute
ist in den Schulen müssen wir eh nie
wieder heizen denn die letzten beiden
corona-winter haben unsere Kinder
erfolgreich abgehärtet ja die können
auch bei minus 20 Grad und offenem
Fenster noch sehr gut lernen aber die
allerbeste Idee kommt gar nicht von uns
die Vorsitzende des Verbandes
unabhängiger Reisebüros schlägt vor
deutsche Rentner sollen den Winter in
der Türkei verbringen damit wir hier
Heizkosten sparen Zitat Reisen gegen
Putin ist doch besser als frieren wegen
Putin und das soll der Staat pro Rentner
mit 500 Euro fördern
staatliche Subventionen für Türkei
reisen das ist ja nun endgültig Wahnsinn
klar ja da haben sie recht absoluter
Wahnsinn damit bis zum Winter zu warten
deswegen fangen wir von Eon jetzt schon
an die ersten Rentner zum Flieger zu
bringen ob sie wollen oder nicht wir
sind eigentlich lieber an der Ostsee ja
aber da ist es zu kalt
gute Reise ja von mir auch Valerie
Niehaus vielen Dank
valeriehaus so meine Damen und Herren
Putins Putins Krieg in der Ukraine wie
Sie sicher wissen nebenbei auch ein
weltweiter inflationsbeschleuniger reden
wir also mal über die soziale Frage so
kurz nach dem ersten Mai dem Tag der
Arbeit bzw wir eigentlich heißen müsste
Tag der Arbeit von der 21 Prozent der
Deutschen nicht leben können weil sie im
Niedriglohnsektor arbeiten so reicht
Deutschland ist wir haben immer noch
einen der größten Niedriglohnsektoren
Europas so und da kommt jetzt halt auch
noch die Inflation als Problem oben
drauf keine guten Aussichten meint auch
dieser sauerländische Nachfahre des
Nostradamus
wir haben wahrscheinlich jedenfalls für
eine gewisse Zeit den Höhepunkt unseres
Wohlstandes hinter uns ja ja bei manchen
reicht das Benzin nur noch für eins von
zwei Privatflugzeugen
andere würden März entgegnen welcher
Wohlstand 40 Prozent der Deutschen haben
gar keine Ersparnisse weil sie schon vor
der Inflation jeden Cent zum Leben
gebraucht haben Rentner Menschen im
Grundsicherung und Niedriglöhner fragen
sich wie Sie Lebensmittel und
Stromrechnung bezahlen sollen
immerhin kommt ab Herbst der neue
Mindestlohn von 12 Euro wenn er denn so
kommt der Arbeitgeberverband BDA
lobbyiert fleißig für Ausnahmeregelung
und der Hauptgeschäftsführer von denen
Steffen Kampeter sagt hier gehe
schließlich nur um einen Austausch Lohn
gegen Leistung und nicht darum ob der
Achtung Beschäftigte in München in der
Innenstadt wohnen und seine Kinder
betreuen lassen kann endlich sagt es mal
einer genau so ist er nämlich der
Geringverdiener erkennt man ja die Vögel
diese lieferando-fahrer die den ganzen
Tag für eine Handvoll Kröten durch die
Stadt düsen bis der Hintern qualmt um
sich dann abends in ihrem 300
Quadratmeter läuft in Schwabing zu
entspannen und das sollen alles die
Arbeitgeber finanzieren zusammen mit dem
Polo fährt der Tochter
gieriges Niedriglöhner pacto
gerade beim Thema Lebensmittel darf die
Politik nicht auf den neuen Mindestlohn
im Herbst warten die Preise für Brot und
Gemüse explodieren jetzt schon vor sich
hin Tatsache ein Bund Lauch ist
plötzlich das ideale Geschenk ja
[Gelächter]
und es ist in Wirklichkeit gar nicht
lustig Inflation erschüttert das
Vertrauen in den Staat und gefährdet so
langfristig die Demokratie immer mehr
Menschen übrigens auch solche Mitarbeit
müssen sich Lebensmittel bei der Tafel
holen einer Institution auf die sich die
deutsche Politik schon viel zu lange
viel zu sehr verlässt mit einer
Selbstverständlichkeit in Essen zum
Beispiel sind die Schlangen jetzt mehr
als doppelt so lang wie noch vor wenigen
Wochen und auch in vielen anderen
Städten schlagen die tafelnalarm weil
man ihnen die Bude einrennt ich habe 65
bis 70 Euro für Essen und Trinken im
Monat zum Leben mein Sachbearbeiter
früher der hat gemeint ja wenn sie
nächste fressen im Entschuldigung wenn
sie nichts mehr zu essen im Kühlschrank
haben muss ich echt manchmal gehen sie
doch zur Tafel
das können die doch nicht machen was
machen sie aber auch ukrainische
Flüchtlinge werden wohl vermehrt vom Amt
zur Tafel geschickt wo aber nur
ehrenamtliche arbeiten und wo die
Lebensmittelspenden zuletzt leider
zurückgegangen sind warum weil die
Supermärkte weniger wegschmeißen was an
sich vernünftig ist aber auch wegen
solcher Knalltüten hier Zoff um die
letzte Rolle Klopapier Hygieneartikel
und Konserven das Bunkern die Hamster am
liebsten weil wenn es alle machen dann
irgendwie muss man mitmachen
nee klar nee dann muss man ja ne wenn
die anderen das auch machen schade dass
ich die Logik beim Impfen nicht
durchgesetzt hat oder
ja
gut
zum Glück kommt jetzt das
Entlastungspaket der Ampel das ist gut
allerdings sind das Einmalzahlungen und
befristete Rabatte die das Problem mit
den Lebensmittelpreisen nicht wirklich
lösen
also fordern Sozialverbände die
Mehrwertsteuer auf Grundnahrungsmittel
ganz abzuschaffen oder und jetzt sage
ich ein ganz schlimmes Wort wie wäre es
denn zur Abwechslung mal mit
Umverteilung
ja ja why not die zehn reichsten
Deutschen haben ihr Vermögen während
Corona fast verdoppelt das ist Fakt und
was da
was da helfen könnte wäre zum Beispiel
eine Erbschaftssteuer die den Namen auch
verdient oder hier die Idee mit der
übergewinnsteuer für Konzerne die gerade
am Krieg verdienen sie ahnen es schon
all das wird es mit der FDP natürlich
niemals geben das ist schade sehr schade
aber komm dafür dass es die gute
Nachricht eröffnet im nächsten Jahr
direkt neben dem Europapark Rust das
Freilichtmuseum Leben wie vor der
Inflation das wird irre wirklich da kann
man jetzt sogar zum Beispiel da kann man
an so einer Fake Tankstelle sehen aus
vergangenen Tagen bestaunen Benzin
tanken für unter 1,60 und die die
Besucher dürfen das Fotografieren
staunen Sie beim Luxus ride über längst
vergessene Gemüsesorten die keiner mehr
bezahlen kann Brokkoli Aubergine oder
Avocado in einer originalgetreu
nachgebauten Sparkasse erklären
Schauspieler das ist früher mal fünf
Prozent Zinsen gab ja und dann weinen
alle das Freilichtmuseum Leben wie vor
der Inflation Eintritt 500 Euro oder
eine Flasche Sonnenblumenöl meine Damen
und Herren
so
immerhin das kommt Tatsache ist
Tatsache ist sein Wohlstand erarbeiten
wird für viele immer schwieriger in
diesem Land und das gilt erst recht für
den Traum von der eigenen Immobilie die
Bauzinsen steigen die Immobilienpreise
sinken aber nicht spätestens da braucht
es also professionelle Beratung
berät
[Musik]
es ist der deutsche Traum endlich das
eigene rein Endhaus indem man zusammen
mit dem geliebten Partner dem Ende
entgegenkompostiert meine Frau und ich
wir haben das mal durchgerechnet und wir
meinen das könnte ganz gut klappen wir
sind ja schließlich Doppelverdiener so
sie sind Studienrat
und sie sind
Krankengymnastin richtig ja sie wollen
eine Eigentumswohnung in Köln kaufen
Eigenkapital 150.000
nee also dafür brauchen wir unseren
Fachmann
Jochen die Herrschaften suchen eine
Immobilie in Köln er ist Studienrat und
sie ist Krankengymnastin
[Gelächter]
so und wissen Sie was der Grundfehler
von denen war zu glauben man könnte sich
in Deutschland eine Immobilie erarbeiten
die Immobilienpreise sind zwischen 2010
und 2019 um fette 53 Prozent gestiegen
da kommt doch Löhne und Gehälter längst
nicht mehr mit und ich weiß genau was
sie zu Hause jetzt denken scheiße ich
arbeite ja auch ich Vollidiot was mache
ich denn jetzt kein Problem
geile Butter oder und die gehört bald
mir und zwar nicht wegen Arbeit oder
wegen Aktien oder Bitcoin nein wegen der
Liebe weil ich diese wunderbare
firmenerbe ich meine natürlich Frau
geirattet habe in der Blüte ihres Lebens
hallo Ingeborg
jedes Jahr werden in Deutschland 400
Milliarden Euro vererbt tatsächlich ist
das der einzige seriöse anlagetipp den
ich ihn geben kann Erben ah da bist du
ja Schatz na freust du dich auf Base
jumpen was ist das denn Base jumpen ja
das wird eine riesen Überraschung
der Gott ist kaputt schatz mach doch
nichts ich fahre ja vorsichtig
[Musik]